The project was
to develop spaces,
both physical and virtual,
that would allow students
and faculty from across
the university to engage
in thinking through making.
We got into it, I think, through
our collaborative teaching
in the Harvard
architecture studies
undergraduate track, which is in
its fifth year now at Harvard.
So new, but there is
an increasing interest
from students at the college to
study through physical making
and visual output.
So we are interested in
finding ways to support that
but also to link that work to
things going on more broadly
across Harvard
University's campus.
So that was our real
agenda, is to be
able to bolster and support
and connect this already
ongoing project to other
initiatives that are
similar across the university.
And we had noticed that
students and faculty were
engaged in making projects.
They were actually
physically producing things
for their other courses.
And we were interested
in trying to figure out
how to foster real
conversation about the objects
that they were making.
So not just thinking
about the technical skills
but actually the
discourse that surrounds
producing objects as
a mode of research
and of knowledge production.
This space is among
the first to address
student academic
pursuits in terms
of thinking through making.
And our grant helps support
the outfitting of that space
through technical means
for these students.
We also, through the
support of the grant,
created a website to
be able to disseminate
and create a kind of visual
means of analysis of what
the students are making.
So the website really
features student work
made through processes of
physical modeling or drawing
that is iterative and
also evolutionary.
It changes as you study
different versions
and permutations of an idea.
And the website really enables
both students and faculty
across the university to look
at what this process produced
and hopefully, affects
how we start thinking
about adjustments to
the pedagogy of the two
studios related to all of
that feedback and reception.
Yeah.
And I think that's
really important.
Because we don't think of this
just as the physical making
space.
But, really, that
virtual discursive space
is really a part of the project.
And that's really
important for us.
And for us, that was
a big part of what we
are interested in developing.
So not just a maker space where
students could come and do
independent projects
but, really,
a space that was both
physical and intellectual
for them to be able to
talk through architectural
discourse, what objects
they were producing
meant, in a sense.
Architects.
They were already embedded
in architectural culture.
They have technical
skills that allow
them to produce objects that are
recognizable as architecture.
The students that come
into architecture studies,
and the students that are
interested in our making space,
by contrast, are coming
from a really wide range
of disciplinary backgrounds.
So we have people
from cellular biology,
from classics, from
engineering, from applied math.
And they don't really
have preconceptions
of what architecture or what
architectural objects are,
which is really exciting.
Because they have
this whole new lens
with which to look at the work.
It's definitely
challenging, because it
means that we have
to bring everyone up
to speed in terms of
some technical skills
and in terms of the
language that we
use to talk about
architecture and the way
that we talk about
architectural objects.
But for us, it's been
really exciting to see
the multiplicity of
ideas and opinions
that comes out of
this interdisciplinary
collaborative space.
And that's where the
interdisciplinary part of our
project--
even though it's
definitely in architecture,
we think about it
as architecture
with broad
interdisciplinary reach.
Yeah.
It's been interesting to craft
a website that also starts
to select and bring
together examples of student
work produced in the two
studios, representative
of students interested in
this track of coursework,
coming from very
different disciplines.
So it's also a way of
making visual and legible,
through means of
website representation,
a digital means of communication
to the university what
these different disciplines
threaded through architecture
as a combination
end up producing.
In addition, it's been
wonderful working with Lisa
on this grant,
because even though we
come at this topic from
two different studios,
addressing it together,
how interdisciplinary
critical thinking can
work through making spaces
has, I think, refined even
exactly how each of the two
studios address this topic--
Yeah, definitely.
--and then complement
each other.
So it's been super
helpful, also,
in terms of shaping
and refining the focus
of our respective classes.
And I think that has a much
further reach going forward
than just the duration of
this grant, which is really
lovely to have as the outcome.
I think, perhaps,
what's come out
of this, though maybe not
matching one-to-one what
we had anticipated
to be the outcomes,
is probably more
productive and actually
more focused in
many ways to feed
the college and the development
of this course of study moving
forward.
So I think to be flexible is
an important piece of advice
that I don't know that we maybe
had foreshadowed or anticipated
quite as much.
I think having a
visible platform
for the work that
we're doing is for me,
an immediate mark of success.
We're attracting more
students to the studios
and generating more interest
in architecture studies.
But I think just
having that visibility
for me is one marker,
and an important one,
of the success of the project.
I agree.
I think the visibility
with the website,
I would imagine, will have a
lasting and longer duration
effect and be a mode
of measuring success
that we don't really
have all the data on yet.
Part of the idea of this project
is that it doesn't end now
but that we've
set up a framework
to be able to continue
to showcase work,
to continue this conversation.
And that was part of what
we had imagined all along,
was that this was the kindling
for an ongoing, longer-term
conversation and that we now
have a pretty robust framework
for making sure that
people can become
engaged when they want to.
And also, that that
framework can evolve.
So if initiatives
in other departments
appeared or found resonance with
things going on in the studios,
or the studios started to
partner with other faculty,
that this website
would enable us a way
to describe the evolution
of this series of studios
available to the students
over the life of the program.
This is the kind of thing that
I feel like maybe, in the past,
we'd have to do
secretly, like, what
are some innovative
ways of teaching?
That now, it feels exciting
that it actually is fully
acknowledged as being valuable
in terms of creative thinking
in the classroom that has
real intellectual weight
and that that doesn't
have to be something that
flies below the radar anymore.